وينضم الان الينا من مستشفى الشفاء في
مدينه غزه مراسلنا اسماعيل الغول اهلا
اسماعيل اذا كالعاده نحاول الوقوف على
المستجدات في راس كل ساعه
تفضل نعم وايضا كالعاده القصف الاسرائيلي
متواصل على قطاع غزه للاسف لم يتوقف ولا
لثانيه واحده على الرغم من انسحاب قوات
الاحتلال من مختلف المحاور وبقي في المحور
الغربي الشمالي لمدينه غزه وهي منطقه حي
الشيخ رضوان اطراف منطقه حي الشيخ رضوان
ومنطقه الامن العام ومحيط منطقه بهلول
صباح هذا اليوم او فجر هذا اليوم عفوا
حاولت قوات الاحتلال التقدم في هذا المحور
لكن يبدو ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه تستمر في
عمليه التصدي ومنع قوات الاحتلال من
التقدم المقاومه نجحت في اعاده نشر قواتها
وفق المصادر الميدانيه التي كانت
والمواطنين الذين كانوا منش في ذاك المكان
ان المقاومه نجحت في التصدي لقوات
الاحتلال ومنعتهم من عمليه التقدم لكن
الملحوظ هذا اليوم ان قوات الاحتلال كانت
على مشارف جريمه جديده بعد قصفها لمنزل
ياوي ما يزيد عن 80 شخصا لكن قدر الله
ولطف الله في هذه العائله بات بدون وحال
دون انفجار هذا الصاروخ يحدثنا اكثر عن
هذه القضيه المتحدث باسم الدفاع المدني
الاستاذ محمود بصل الذي عايش هذه الاجواء
لو تحدثنا اكثر عن هذه المجزره والجريمه
التي كانت على مشارف عن تقع نعم هو صبيحه
هذا اليوم كان هناك استهداف ل طبعا منزل
بالسكان في منطقه الكتيبه في وسط مدينه
غزه هذا المنزل كان يحتوي على اكثر من 80
مواطن تم استهداف هذا المنزل بصاروخ حربي
وبحمد لله انه هذا الصاروخ لم ينفجر ولو
انفجر لتحدثنا عن عدد كبير من الشهداء
طبعا نتحدث من خلال مشاهدتنا لمكان هذا
الحدث والحديث مع الشهود الذين كانوا
متواجدين في هذا المكان يتحدث عن اكثر من
40 طفل في هذا المكان في هذا المنزل بمعنى
اننا نتحدث عن جريمه بكل ما تحمل الكلمه
كانت تنوي اسرائيل ارتكابها في هذا المكان
ولم يكن هذا يعني هو لم تكن هذه هي
الجريمه يعني الاولى التي ترتكبها اسرائيل
بحق المواطنين في قطاع غزه بالامس كان
هناك لنا زياره في منطقه الشمال
وراينا المشاهد المؤلمه لمجزره ال ابو
علبه وحقيقه نتحدث عن اكثر من 83 مواطن
كانوا متواجدين في هذا المكان استشهد يعني
عدد كبير منهم وبقي عدد ايضا يعني متواجد
وعلى قيد الحياه اسرائيل حتى لظه رغم كل
الحديث عن حمايه المدنيين رغم كل الزيارات
الدوليه والحديث عن منع ارتكاب الجرائم
الا ان اسرائيل حتى اللحظه ترتكب المجازر
بحق المدنيين العزل في قطاع غزه واسرائيل
للاسف الشديد تتحدث على ان هناك مطلوبين
متواجدين ونتحدث بكل بصريح العباره تتحدث
على ان هذه المنازل التي يتم استهدافها
يوجد بداخلها مطلوبين تريد قتلهم اسرائيل
في حال اي استهداف ما ما الحديث عن مقدرات
الدفاع المدني كيف كيف سيتم التعامل واقع
الدفاع المدني حقيقه صعب جدا في قطاع غزه
خصوصا بعد انهيار المنظومه الصحيه وانهيار
منظومه الدفاع المدني بنسبه 70% تقريبا
بعد عمليات الاستهداف للطواقم واستهداف
للمعدات واستهداف للحفارات نحن بنتحدى
موجوده في قطاع غزه وال والاشكاليه الكبرى
الان التي تواجه طواقمنا هو عدم توفر ال
عدم توفر الوقود وحتى هذه اللحظه لم يصل
طواقم الدفاع المدني اي لتر واحد من
الوقود ونحن حقيقه يعني اوقفنا عدد كبير
من امكانياتنا حتى يعني نستطيع ان نكمل
المشوار لخدمه ابناء شعبنا نعم هذه
امكانات الدفاع المدني تحاول الطواقم
الدفاع المدني بشكل متكرر ان تعمل في
الميدان بكل قواها على الرغم من المعيقات
الكبيره التي تواجه طواقم الدفاع المدني
علما ان المناطق الغربيه التي وقع فيها
هذا القصف ولم ينفجر
الصاروخ يوجد بها اعداد كبيره من النازحين
حتى هذه اللحظه واي قصف اسرائيلي قد يوقع
عشرات القتلى والضحايا في مدينه غزه هذا
هو الواقع وحتى هذه اللحظه نرصد باقي
المستجدات اشكرك اشكرك اسماعيل على هذه
المعلومات من مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه